the chicky science show clips
yeah no christopher has definitely
revolutionized as you say not only
potentially the way we can treat
different genetic diseases but also just
as a research tool um like with
christmas screens um to investigate and
understands um how the cells are working
but um like with crispr cast 9 the
canonical system in addition to seeing
finger nucleuses
and talons what they the way that they
work is by inducing double-stranded
breaks and so double stranded breaks um
are quite deleterious for a cell it's
it's a major form of damage for a cell
and it's had um race concerns in
different papers about
inducing the dna damage response in
terms of the p53 mediated response and
so there's concerns over not only um
basically the safety of
having um
an editing machinery that induces a
double-stranded break and so that's led
to um
finding solutions that edit without
having a double-stranded break that
might be potentially safer in case there
was any off-target um editing going on
and so um was that why
you ended up discovering uh base editing
or how do base editing come about could
you explain a bit about that yeah
it's a great question um
so as i think you just gave a a great
concise summary of
of uh double strand breaks and their
role in in gene editing
you know it really began with maria
jason's seminal discovery that a double
strand break
can stimulate
increased rates of homologous
recombination at the cut site
and because
the
the use of
the connection between double-stranded
breaks which is cutting a chromosome
into two pieces
and gene editing really began with
maria jason and others discovering the
relationship between double-stranded
breaks and homologous recombination
products
i think there was a
great hope early on
in the gene editing
field's history that being able to to
make targeted double-stranded breaks
with these programmable nucleases
whether they're zinc finger nucleuses or
talons or crispr cast 9
would provide a way to to do precise
gene correction
unfortunately uh we now know that
this process of homology directed repair
or hdr
as it's called uh which is
the way that a double-stranded break can
be turned into a precise edit
is is unfortunately not general and
virtually no therapeutically relevant
cell types
support
hdr with an efficiency that would be
considered useful
for at least four therapeutic
applications as a research tool it is
widely used and in vitro under a variety
of conditions you can
find cells that support hdr
but you know perhaps tellingly i think
when i checked
last month
so february 2021
somebody asked me how many crispr
clinical trials are there right now and
the answer is so i looked it up there's
43 of them
how many of them
are trying to use a double-stranded
break to induce precise gene repair
through homology directed repair the
answer is zero
all of the therapeutic trials
using crispr right now
are using crispr to disrupt genes
because the branch of fate that happens
once you make a double-stranded cut in a
chromosome
is predominantly in most cell types to
to lead to gene disruption
uh through indel formation meaning the
cell is desperately trying to get the
ends of the broken chromosome back
together
and in the process it will
uh often get the ends together perfectly
but then the nuclease can just chop up
the site again and you you go back to
the broken chromosome so every now and
then the act of joining the ends back
together makes a mistake and
those mistakes slow down the process of
subsequent cutting so you you see an
accumulation of those dead end products
collectively called indels because they
have insertions and deletions it's
mostly deletions it should be called
dell ends it's just more awkward to say
i suppose
um
and so
to be clear you know making indels in a
targeted gene
can be quite useful but you have to get
kind of lucky if that is your
therapeutic strategy one really
important example where scientists
where biology did provide that luck is
sickle cell anemia beta thalassemia some
blood diseases
caused by
homozygous mutations in
the adult hemoglobin gene called
beta-globin
you can compensate for those mutations
not by fixing directly the beta-globin
genes i mean you could do that in
principle that's just harder to do it
with the nucleus for the reasons we just
described
but instead you can use gene disruption
to fix to rescue some of those diseases
by disrupting a gene that is involved in
the silencing of fetal hemoglobin
so as i'm sure you know
and and your audience is probably
becoming increasingly familiar with
uh we're born with redundant sets of
hemoglobin genes we have a fetal
hemoglobin
set of genes that
is responsible for most of our
hemoglobin when when we are gestating as
fetuses and then around the time of
birth it begins to be silenced and adult
hemoglobin gene expression begins to be
turned on instead
so researchers have identified many of
the genes involved in silencing that
fetal hemoglobin
and if you can disrupt those genes then
you can actually disrupt those genes
then you can actually
turn back on fetal hemoglobin
and almost everybody who has defective
beta-globin genes has healthy fetal
hemoglobin genes
so
it's probably a reasonably strong
selection during embryogenesis
so so even if you if you lose the
genetic lottery and you inherit or are
born with two
defective
adult beta globin genes you can still
lead a normal life
if you have mutations that disrupt
silencing of fetal hemoglobin a very
lucky number of people a small very
lucky number of well you could argue
they're lucky and unlucky
were born with all of those mutations
they have mutations in their adult
hemoglobin that should give them
serious blood diseases but they also
have mutations in the genes that are
necessary to silence fetal hemoglobin so
they end up being okay
um and so a bunch of really smart
scientists and companies
have exploited this observation to use
crispr cas9 or other
double strand break inducing
programmable nucleuses
to disrupt the
genes that silence fuel hemoglobin so
that's an example of how gene disruption
can actually
benefit a patient
but the reason i said you have to get
kind of lucky is
you know there are a number of small
miracles that all had to take place to
create this perfect storm of a situation
where
gene disruption can rescue a genetic
disease
most of the time
in order to benefit a patient we need to
fix a mutation not simply disrupt it
further
the mutation has already disrupted the
gene
or or created a version of the gene that
leads to health problems
and in most cases simply disrupting the
gene further isn't expected to benefit
patients instead we need to
mediate precise gene correction instead
of gene disruption
so i think that's sort of a background
that um you know i don't think is a any
kind of great new insight it's it's been
known in human genetics for a long time
that the nature of most mutations is
that they need to be fixed or
complemented
rather than further disrupted in order
to
rescue a disease phenotype
but the story about how base editing
began
then
took that background and married it
again with the serendipitous
prospective postdoc candidates
application this is alexis comore
now a professor at ucsd
um alexis uh was a prospective postdoc
interviewed in my group um our lab was
very impressed with her
uh i made her an offer and as i often do
with post talks even before they arrived
we began to exchange emails about okay
what what projects did you work on so
when they arrive they can hit the ground
running
and and so i asked her what are you
interested in doing and and
she
emailed me a list of
of uh
sort of proto project ideas one of which
i thought was was kind of interesting
she was
proposing the use of puff proteins which
are programmable
sort of programmable rna binding
proteins
to mediate
changes to rna
and
you know i told her
i think this is interesting but
what would potentially be
particularly transformative i think i
used
a fairly grandiose language in my email
to her which i've now been asked to dig
up several times by a journalist
and i think this was back in 2013 so a
long time ago
2013 uh i i told her if you can
develop a way
to do chemistry directly on a base pair
to change one base pair to another base
pair in dna
given the challenges that were beginning
to be understood with homology directed
repair and making double stranded breaks
i think the wording i used was
you you could you would transform the
life sciences and quite possibly
medicine or something like that
and so we began to brainstorm uh how to
do this and um
uh you know she pointed out uh so we
quickly focused on
cited indiaminases
i think i had proposed that she look at
some of the enzymes known to turn c's
into use and use of course pair like
teas
she raised to the i think very good
point that these daminases seem to work
on single-stranded dna and of course
most genomic dna is not single stranded
and then
as we thought about what different dna
binding proteins
to use
i think in a subsequent email i pointed
out that the
single stranded requirement of most
yaminases
doesn't bother me too much because cas9
is known to unwind the dna
into single strands
into single strands
and you know i think at the time that
sort of made logical sense but
i didn't fully appreciate how enabling
that
simple ability of cast 9 to create a
single stranded dna r-loop
when it engages the target dna sequence
was and uh you know as as a sort of
uh perfect storm of
of uh
of molecular interactions you know cas9
because it has to pair the guide rna
in a watson creek style with
one of the target dna strands it has to
unwind the dna double helix so that one
strand can pair with the guide rna and
that leaves the other strand as a sort
of free single stranded dna bubble
and it's within that
single stranded bubble that base editing
occurs on the quote non-targeted strand
uh so the crispr
biologist named the strand that pairs
with the guide rna as the targeted
strand
but for base editing it's actually the
other strand that gets edited first
um so so uh so that was the basic idea
and we even in early on uh talked about
how we would probably have to
impede
the uracil dna glycosylase enzymes that
otherwise are very highly evolved to
look for uracil in dna and cut it out
because cytosine turns out to be the
least stable of the four dna bases
and uh you know your roughly one billion
cytosines in each of your cells
undergo spontaneous deamination
at a rate that results in several
hundred of them every day becoming
yourself
so that would probably be an
unacceptable level of mutation
uh were it not for the fact that your
cells
and i think just about every kind of
cell has evolved
uh very efficient mechanisms to
constantly look for these uracils in dna
and cut them out and then replace them
with seeds
so
so we identified a
a small protein inhibitor that would
shut down that process called uracil
glycosylase inhibitor that we could
localize to the side of the base edit to
try to block
uracil glycosylation at least
transiently at that site
and then the final piece came
has an insight that alexis had uh
following
her discussions with other group members
so at that time we had the
cited in the eminence piece the cast
nine piece the
uh the earthquake glycosylase piece and
we were getting
you know okay amounts of base editing
maybe 10 or 15 editing
uh thanks to the ugi it was reasonably
clean
but we were trying to get the process to
be more efficient and
you know we
speculated that the ceiling of
efficiency was probably going to be 50
uh using that architecture because
if you create a ug miss pair the cell
has to figure out whether the u is the
correct information or the g is the
correct information
and it's going to resolve that
disagreement either in your favor
creating a ua base pair which is what
you want or it'll go back to the
starting material to create a cg
and uh and so we thought well maybe we
could and this is really the insight
that alexis brought to my attention that
uh she had a hunch that if you nicked
the g containing strand
that that would cue mismatched repair
which in eukaryotic cells uses nicks
to signify newly synthesized and
therefore less validated dna
that that the nick would cue mismatch
repair to replace the segment containing
the g with the newly synthesized dna
segment and because there was a uracil
on the opposite side of the double helix
when it was re-synthesizing that that
new dna segment it would put in an a
opposite the u and that would complete
the conversion of the information on
both strands
to what you know from what used to be a
cg base pair now to a ua or a ta base
pair
and so that adding that simple nick
which
required just a single mutation
put back into uh
into our be2 base editor
resulted in be3 which was the first you
know reasonably efficient cytosine based
editor
and and we showed that
it was now able to think in our original
paper you know edit 30 or 40 percent
sometimes 70 percent
but clearly showing you could you could
actually exceed 50 editing
by biasing that
mismatch repair process which would
otherwise
to first approximation be a coin toss to
instead favor the repair of both dna
strands the way you wanted
and now of course base editors have been
improved by many labs including our own
over many generations and
you know we've
in some recent experiments
that multiple people in the lab have
done at multiple different target sites
for multiple
uh
genetic diseases they get close to 100
editing
so it's really come a long way and you
know there were uh in fact a new first
year graduate student named lily in the
lab has achieved 100 editing at multiple
target sites uh in including in in
patient-derived uh inpatient fibroblasts
primary fibroblasts so
uh so based on has come a long way and
and there were moments
early on even
right when we
published the paper in 2016
where we wondered are we ever going to
be able to achieve
you know
80 90 100 editing even though i think
for the vast majority of genetic
diseases to benefit patients you don't
need editing that efficient
um but the answer actually is yes you
can get close to 100 base editing
using the variety of improvements that
the community
uh have now advanced from our original
work in 2016.
and i should also mention that
two groups in japan
professors nishida and kondo working
together
reported in science several months after
our initial base editor paper that
alexis led
reported in science a similar system
where they used a different deaminase
uh but also with cas9 also nicking the
opposite strand
and reported similar results so
that was also welcome news because it
really showed that
um that you know independent groups were
were finding the same
uh outcomes that you could now make for
the first time targeted
single base pair changes without cutting
the dna double helix without cutting a
chromosome into pieces
in a living mammalian cell in a in a
living human cell
and that really of course got us
fixated on okay let's figure out how to
how to fix as many possible types of
mutations that are responsible for
genetic disease and that researchers
might want to install in cells to study
the properties of genes
as possible but the boundary conditions
are you can't make double stranded
breaks
well no that's really incredible to hear
the the backstory to how base editing
started and it's incredible also to hear
that you're approaching 100 efficiency
um
which is definitely um pretty amazing
considering
um like where it started with um and say
obviously you've now taken um base
editing uh to beam therapeutics which uk
founded and you're trying to
now take um the the basic science and
discovery and taking it to being able to
treat different genetic diseases
and so um
out of the different genetic diseases
what um what do you think based editing
will be used for first in terms of
getting to
patients in the clinic
yeah well so beam has disclosed a
variety of of programs that they
plan to bring to the clinic
this year or shortly there afterwards
and
based on their announcements
they've disclosed that they are
they have developed base editing
strategies to treat
some blood diseases
they've developed base editing to base
editing strategies to
treat some metabolic diseases as well
like
alfie alpha-1 anti-trypsin
deficiency
and i think they've also disclosed that
they have
been able to base at it to correct some
genetic alleles that are involved in
some blindness diseases as well
i
always want to make sure that
anything i'm sharing is something that
they've already shared so
just point people to the beam
therapeutics website where they i think
list the programs that they've publicly
disclosed
but i think maybe from from a more meta
perspective
uh
you know a decision that i admire that
that beam has made is uh
they recognize that the platform
was so broad
in its potential applicability to
diseases that they would not focus on
just one
organ one type of disease one delivery
modality
but instead
beam has i think done a great job trying
to
advance as many programs as possible to
cover the broadest possible range of
of diseases and therefore of patients
that could benefit from base editing
technology
and so they have
really chosen to
to pursue as many programs that meet um
you know some key criteria like is there
bulletproof biology that relates the
correction of the mutation to the
correction of the disease
uh is there a delivery modality that can
uh that is promising to deliver the base
editors to
the cells that are anticipated to
lead to
disease rescue if corrected
and
you know what are the
uh
uh what are the potential base editing
strategies
that can fix the mutation with the best
current base editing technologies known
and you know fortunately i think is a
sign of of the progress that has led to
literally hundreds of base editors now
being published
uh having been published
that third criteria
is increasingly proving easier and
easier to me
that with all of the different kas9 pam
variants
uh the different cast proteins that have
proven to be compatible with pace
editors including a variety of cast 12
variants
that uh targeting is
is increasingly
uh
uh not an issue
and uh
and even sort of positioning the target
nucleotide with respect to the base
editing window has also been simplified
not just by the fact that there are now
lots of different pamp sequences that
you can target
that is lots of places in the genome
where you can park a base editor
but researchers have started to have
some
success uh controlling where the base
editing window is and how wide or how
narrow it is
and so that diversity of literally
hundreds of base editors that are
available now
um
greatly increase the chance that if you
have a mutation you're trying to correct
uh you can do so with uh with a base
editor without too much trouble well
then that's super exciting because yeah
that's what i'm um obviously the
concerns for base editing is you
obviously have cas9 coming into the dna
site
opening up the dna region and obviously
in theory there could be
potential for of target editing of
different sites so having control over
that window is a great advance
right and and uh researchers have shown
that you can
both
mutate the deaminases to
uh control that window and you can also
mutate the cas9
and in in maybe intellectually at least
my favorite
solution you can circularly permute cas9
proteins something that dave savage has
had success with and so we collaborated
with
with his lab and showed that these
circularly permuted
cast nines do indeed change enough the
topology of the r loop relative to the
deaminase that you can
move
in some cases broaden in other cases
actually move over
the base editing window
so
so having a sort of bookshelf with lots
and lots of different books that each
have slightly different properties
has proven to be
especially useful for
enabling base editing to
serve as many purposes as possible it is
at as many target sites as
as pos as possible with as many
performance characteristics as is needed
to
enable the research or the therapeutic
application of interest
you